[Musique]
début de soirée en fanfare au gymnase de
la fontaine blanche le ton est donné la
corrida est un événement sportif mais
aussi festif et convivial et s'appelait
apparemment puisque en 13 ans le nombre
d'inscrits est passé de 300 à 1200 on
pensait que c'était une très mauvaise
date entre les deux fêtes et on s'est
aperçu que c'est une excellente date
alors est-ce que c'est entre les fêtes
les gens viennent un petit peu courir je
sais qu'on a eu des gens des découvreurs
de calvi de marseille de strasbourg
alors je pense qu'ils viennent en
famille sheikh chambray les tours et
après by jybo on va participer à la
corrida
certains participants aux le chic pour
animé et coloré la soirée comme ceux de
la ccl 37 l'association les copains
coureurs nés une association 80 les
rencontrer et puis on est relié par
l'album plus bonheur de courir ensemble
quoi enfin les mamies elles sont un peu
derrière mamie gaga avec un peu normal à
70 ans
le mot d'ordre c'est pas d'obligation et
pas de contraintes uniquement plaisir de
s'amuser tous ensemble il n'ya pas
d'élite chez nous on s'amuse et on court
ensemble
[Musique]
au programme une course de 7 km 234 très
exactement dans le froid et le
brouillard
cette 13e édition les deux boucle semble
bouclée en à peine plus de vingt minutes
pour les coureurs les plus aguerris et
qu'importe si certains mettent trois
fois plus de temps l'essentiel est bien
de participer relativement bien la fin
un peu dur là j'ai eu la chance de
trouver un collègue avait défini qu'il
ne cherchait pour pour essayer de
grimper un peu mieux classé mais ça a
été pendant un coup de chapeau à la
petite centaine de bénévoles qui rendent
possible la corrida sur le parcours ou
ravitaillement avec un buffet qui
contribuent aussi certainement à sa
popularité